Houston, ich hab ein Problem. Könnt ihr mir Hilfe schicken? Bitte, es ist ein Notfall. Hallo, kann mich niemand hören? Oh nein, die Verbindung ist unterbrochen. Touchpad, was kannst du mir heute erzählen? Ich sitze im Raumschiff, gesichtvoller Tränen. Hier sprechen zwei Männer, sie lachen mich aus. Ihr Podcast schallt bis in den Weltraum hinaus. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir. Danke auch, ich möchte.
Und dir, Flo in den Wölk. Genau, Publikum eins heute, aber Zuschauerschaft auf jeden Fall gering. Vielen Dank an alle Zuhörer, dass sie reingesappt haben, dass sie beim Durchzappen durch das Podcastprogramm hier hängen geblieben sind, sich angezogen gefühlt haben von Stefan Tietzes markante Stimme. Ich habe mich neulich gefragt, warum gibt es noch keinen, vielleicht gibt es auch
noch keinen Podcast wie Switch
Reloaded, der andere Podcast
parodiert. Sehr gute Idee.
Und ich finde, wir sollten mal
einen neuen Podcast starten, wo
wir einfach jede Woche
einen anderen Podcast parodieren.
Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Und der ganze Podcast ist
eine Parodie des anderen Podcasts. Aber sind wir gut in Parodien?
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind sehr, sehr schlecht in Parodien.
Ich kam voll. Und ich kam auf die Idee auch nur, weil ich dachte, dass wir sehr gut parodierbar sind.
Weil lustiges Intro am Anfang, Randomness. Zu lang und zu leise.
Pure Randomness, ECE-Stories, Rewe, aber nicht Rewe-Stories, sondern nur über die letzten fünf Minuten des Einkaufs bei der Kassiererin, dann irgendwelche halbgaren Medieninsider oder sowas. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind sehr gut parodierbar. Auch in unseren Stimmen, wie wir reden, unsere Rollenaufteilung ist gut parodierbar, glaube ich. Total, also macht das, kommt uns zuvor und startet einen Parodie-Podcast, bevor wir es tun. Das sind Drohungen, wir sprechen das als Drohung aus. Weil wir würden es tun, aber wir können es nicht. Genau, und ihr müsst euch dann einfach durch einen extrem schlecht parodierten Podcast quälen, falls ihr nicht sagt, ich nehme es selber in die Hand. Ihr habt Verantwortung, okay? Ansonsten müssen wir da durchkommen und müssen irgendwie Felix Lobrecht parodieren und das wollt ihr nicht hören. Ja, ich war da neulich auch Berlinerischheit, aber das ist auch das Einzige. Genau, also wie gesagt, ihr seid jetzt wirklich gefragt, liebe Hörer, nehmt die Podcast-Equipel in die Hand und legt los. Vielen Dank übrigens an Timo für dieses Intro. Dankeschön. Was wäre denn ein guter Name? Podcast Reloaded. Switch Catcatcher, Podcatcher Reloaded. Ja, Pod Switch, sowas in der Richtung, könnt ihr ja gucken. Ist ja auch noch Brainstorming. Ehrlich gesagt, wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht, dass der Name des Podcasts nicht so wahnsinnig wichtig ist. Deswegen kann man eigentlich machen, was man möchte. Stimmt, Namen sind nicht so wichtig. Das muss man sich immer, also wir appellieren nochmal an unsere Seite fornames.com, also names, names, names, names.com, weil man macht sich viele Gedanken, also die meisten exklusiv die ersten fünf Bandproben sind ja, wie heißen wir eigentlich? Und aber auch dann analog dazu die ersten fünf Interviews, wenn man es mal geschafft hat, sind, wie seid ihr eigentlich auf den Bandnamen gekommen? Also irgendwie zieht es sich durch. Erfahrungsgemäß ist es ja egal. Es ist egal und die letzten fünf Bandmeetings sind dann immer, war es so eine gute Idee, den lustigen Bandtitel zu nehmen. Genau, haben wir den besten Namen schon gehabt. Hätten wir uns wirklich Atomic Dustbin nennen sollen, war das wirklich eine gute Idee.
War bei uns auch super anstrengend, wir hießen ja erst X-Packt und dann Binky sagt du und ich sag mal so, obwohl der erste Name grauenhaft ist, ist halt so ein cooles Wort mit X, weil wir sind 13 Jahre alt und kennen die englische Sprache noch nicht. Und weil ihr noch was vor euch habt, man kann noch einiges von euch erwarten, Expect. Genau, richtig. Also man hat irgendwelche Erwartungen rein in diesen Namen oder glaubt auch mal, man hat es richtig nachgeschlagen im Langenscheid-Wörterbuch und findet die Sprache halt cool, dieses große X, wer aber natürlich auch ohne Ehemann von geschrieben ist, sondern einfach nur X. So, und dann ist der Name halt scheiße und irgendwann geht einem mit 17 das Licht auf, dass der Name scheiße ist und dann nimmt man sich Binky und sagt, boah, weil man das für einen besseren Namen hält, aber alle sind verwirrt, die ganzen großen Labels, ja. Die schicken die Checks, wo völlig falsch hin.
Die ganzen
ja, es ist ein bisschen vergleichbar, die ganzen großen
Freizeitzentren-Besitzer
aus dem Kreis Unna waren dann verwirrt.
Wer sind jetzt blinkig, sagt du,
die kriegen nicht so einfach einen Auftritt wie Expect.
Weil Expect hat sich halt irgendwie
eingespielt in die Ohren.
Das heißt aber, technisch gesehen ist der Name
Expect jetzt wieder frei.
Also wenn ihr den aufgegeben habt, dann ist er jetzt wieder frei verfügbar. Ich glaube, Bandnamen bleiben besetzt. Ja? Ja. Okay, gut, also ich dachte jetzt vielleicht auch, eine Chance, einen Parodie-Podcast namens X-Back zu machen, ist jetzt noch möglich. Green Day hießen früher, glaube ich, Sweet Children und ist der bessere Name eigentlich. Und dann die dritte Inkarnation ist Green Green Children und einfach so, wir kommen näher, wir kommen, ich weiss, dass wir näher kommen.
Green Children ist es noch nicht, aber wir kommen zumindest einen Schritt näher.
Das ist die Weiterentwicklung, es gibt ja die drei Pokémon-Stufen.
Green Day am Apparate oder was? Green Day war angerufen, ja, wir sollen das nicht mehr erwähnen.
Punk ist tot.
Hätte ich auch nie verstanden, ehrlich gesagt, das war immer so ein Gag im Neomagazin-Autorenraum. Punk ist nicht tot, Punk steht gerade an der Rewe-Kasse oder sowas. Ja, okay. Und wir sassen immer da, fremdartig, wie zwei Aliens, die von ihrem Volk hingeschickt wurden, um den Neomagazin-Autorenraum zu beobachten. Sassen wir mal drin und haben natürlich immer mitgelacht. Klar. Wir beide haben ja auch, muss man sagen, uns da so durchgefaked. Total. Weil wir ja auch nie genau alle popkulturellen Referenzen verstanden haben. Popkulturelle Referenzen, keine Ahnung, Politik, keine Ahnung, immer, na ja, der sieht echt aus ein bisschen wie der junge Ernst Schweber, oder? Und wir beiden, Ernst Schweber, ja, total. Ich möchte doch jemanden von der Tanke haben. Und ja, ganz furchtbar. Ich glaube, so werden Aliens auch hier auf der Erde ankommen. Einfach immer viel mitlachen. Viel so bei den Präsidenten-Meetings, dann einfach viel mitlachen und nicken. Und ja, ja, ja, die Schüler wabbeln nach vorne und hinten, so viel wird da genickt. Und ich glaube, so kommen die ganz gut durch. Ich finde, wenn man in so einem Freundeskreis ist und abends kommen neue Leute dazu, sind es, also sind häufig Leute, die sehr laut sind und sich in den Vordergrund drängen, nicht weil sie viel sagen oder viel beitragen, sondern einfach weil sie sehr laut lachen. Also diese Art Mensch, wenn man die, wenn die einem begegnet, aus einer Außenperspektive, findet die gar nicht die unsympathischsten Menschen. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Zum Beispiel immer sehr gut zu beobachten im Kino. Kino ist ja wirklich so ein bisschen der gesellig feindlichste Ort, den es gibt. Aus gutem Grund, weil man nicht reden soll im Kino. Aber es gibt dann immer so eine Gruppe von acht Leuten, die in einer Reihe sitzen, wo man immer wirklich so wie so eine Werbebildkamera machen kann, Spaß in der Mitte, ganz heiß und nach außen wird es kühler und kühler. Bisschen zu Neid. Bisschen zu Neid, der schon so nach ganz vorne gebeugt und sich so versucht, über drei Personen hinweg zu beugen und so. Was, wo bedacht ihr gerade? Man kommt nie rein. Wo, was, genau, was war jetzt der Witz? Ich habe es gerade nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe vorne die Pointe nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe es akustisch nie gehört. Einfach immer zwei Pointen hinterherhängen. Ganz furchtbar. Dann immer einen Witz reinruft, niemand lacht, den noch mal hinterher, lauter hinterher reinruft, dann dreht sich einer um und sagt, ja, haben wir schon am ersten Mal gehört. Und dann ist auch der Abend irgendwie im Arsch, auf eine Art. Man kann sich aber auch nicht ganz abkapseln, man kann auch nicht sein Schicksal akzeptieren und einfach da sind und sagen, gut, ich bin jetzt nicht Teil der Gruppe, ich bin so ein Außenverteidiger, der irgendwie nicht dabei ist. Und immer so, warum jubelt ihr? Haben wir ein Tor geschossen? Warum soll ich zu euch kommen? Jubeln wir jetzt, umarmen wir uns. Ist es weinen oder warum Hände am Kopf? Weinen oder Jubel? Wein oder Jubel, gebt mir einen Daumen, gebt mir einen Daumen. Keine Chance. Keine Chance. Aber lasst euch gesagt sein, von jemandem, der auch oft Selbstzweifel hatte, bin ich cool genug, bin ich zu cool. Aber jemand, der dann auch oft im Freundeskreis sagte, ha fuck, was mache ich hier eigentlich, weil es liegt nicht an dir, es liegt an deinem Platz, es liegt häufig an deinem Platz. Wenn du außen sitzt, hast du verloren, egal wie cool du bist. Dann oder abends, wenn du dann in so einer, ich hatte mal hier so ein Essen mit Kollegen und ich saß ganz blöd ganz am Rand, ab vor Kopf und da war so eine lange Tafel. Das war auch immer, alle reden miteinander, oft auch gegenüber voneinander und man selbst hat niemanden gegenüber und hängt dann so zwischen Gesprächen, kommt die irgendwo rein und hängt dann nur an den zwei Leuten, die neben dir sitzen. Hast du vielleicht sogar Pech? Und neben dir sitzen zwei, die eng befreundet sind oder so. Und der andere dreht sich weg. Dann wirst du quasi ausgenockt aus dem Abend. Und da war ich danach sehr schlecht gegangen, weil ich dachte, du hast echt nie gut performt und so. Das müsst ihr euch jetzt nicht eignen, weil nach dem Abend zu sagen, man hat nicht gut performt, spricht auch nicht für einen Selbstwert. Naja, man muss wissen, man muss wissen, wo man steht. Genau. Und in der gleichen Konstellation ein Jahr später habe ich halt genau in der Mitte gesessen von dieser Tafel. Und das war total toll. Einfach so wie Jesus beim Abendmahl, so alles spielt dir zu und du musst einfach nur die Arme aufmachen. Nee, weil es ist das Beste, Jesus hatte den besten Platz.
Jesus hatte den besten Platz. Stimmt, Jesus abmal ist genau eine Repräsentation davon, dass die Leute, die außen sind, alle sich so viel zeugen.
Was hast du gesagt? Wer ist Eduard? Ich habe nur kurz, wer Eduard ist. Ich komme nicht.
Aber das sind die armen Säue. Judas war da als Jesus. Der hat sogar in dem gleichen Jahr, im gleichen Ort gelebt, wo fucking Jesus kam und er sass außen. Stell dir vor, du bist am letzten Abendmahl und verstehst kein einziges Wort, weil dir irgendwie Eun und Gläun, die ganz die Ohren ablabern von ihrem Zwergenscheiß, interessiert dich nicht. Ja, wie Eun, Gläun und Sonic the Hedgehog, die ganz außen saßen, abgeschnitten wurden, auch bei Da Vinci nur halb drauf sind.
Und du versuchst immer so wegzukommen von diesem Gespräch, körperlich, aber es geht halt nicht. Auch eine weirde Tafel, dass die alle auf einer Seite saßen. Ganz weirde Tafel. Side-Sitting. Einfach so, kann nicht jemand auf die andere Seite, nee, nee, da ist der Fotograf. Da ist die Kamera. Achsen, Guckensprung. Ja. Genau, und da saß ich genau in der Mitte wie Jesus und das Beste an diesem Platz ist. Also deswegen immer früh da sein, immer lächerlich viel zu früh da sein, drei Stunden, vor dem Abend da sein, in die Mitte setzen. Und dann könnt ihr nämlich, zum einen habt ihr die Möglichkeit zu wechseln, zu springen zwischen Gesprächen. Manchmal ist ein Links besser früh als rechts. Man hat ja immer mal die Momente, wo man nicht so viel beitragen kann und sagen kann. Und dann immer schön wechseln zwischen den Tischhälften, das ist super angenehm und cool. Das kann man gut empfehlen oder man kann sich individuell, man kann mit jedem einzelnen Gespräch beginnen, man kann Leute hinzuholen, Leute rausdrängen aus dem Gespräch. Wirklich ein kurzes Timeout geben, einfach mal kurz, auch mit einem Handzeichen, einfach so ein Stopp. Ein Handzeichen kurz. Nein, wir wollen dich gerade nicht dabei haben, kann es gleich wiederkommen.
Jetzt wo wir gerade bei Jesus sind, man muss sagen, ich finde, die Römer hätten die Kreuzigung noch ein bisschen schlimmer machen können, wenn sie diese drei Kreuze nicht nebeneinander, sondern gegenüber gestellt hätten. So dass man wirklich dem anderen. Aber so ganz nah. So ganz nahe gegenüber. Und dann vor allem einfach den beiden von diesen anderen Verbrechern, keine Ahnung, wer die waren, Joe und Blow oder keine Ahnung, wer die war, vergessen. Leoin, Gloin und Sonic the Hedgehog. Ja, genau. Einfach so von denen, den Jesus weniger mag, haben die da vorausgefunden. Und der auch starken Mundgeruch hat. Genau, direkt vor die Nase und dann wirklich immer so, Alter, komm, jetzt ... Was doch unangenehm ist, genau vor die Nase ist, so leicht höher, dass man so den Mund vor der Nase, ich kann mir nichts bestimmlos vorstellen, wirklich, den Mund einer fremden Person direkt vor der Nase zu haben.
Ja, stimmt, so ein bisschen höher. So ein bisschen leicht höher.
Oh Gott, wie unangenehm. Können wir zumindest die Kreuze umstellen? Leute, Leute,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, bitte, nein!
Furchtbar.
Das ist die schlimmste
Todesstrafe der Welt, glaube ich.
Ist wirklich so mit jemand anderem zusammengebunden.
Aber Kreuzigen war schon ein Thing, oder? Das hat sich jetzt niemand ausgedacht
bei der Bibel. Nö,
ich glaube, das war schon eine Idee.
Wie jetzt? Also,
dass man den da aufhängt, aufnagelt? Und woran sterben die dann? Am Altersschwech? Im Grunde ja. Das Rentensystem war halt auch unter aller Sau. Also da hast du halt auch eine Lebenserwartung von maximal 19. Kommt daher was am Kreuz haben? Weiß ich nicht. Aber doch, ich glaube, wenn man sagt, der hat ein breites Kreuz, ich glaube schon, dass das noch eine ganz makabere Erinnerung an die Kreuzigung ist. Glaube ich schon, oder? Weil ansonsten gibt es ja gar keinen Sinn. Ich verstehe nicht Kreuz, weil ich werde immer korrigiert, weil Kreuzschmerzen sind im unteren Rücken. Aber ein breites Kreuz meint den oberen Rücken, ne? Diese V-Form. Ein breites Kreuz haben gleich breiter oberer Rücken, breite Schultern.
Ja, stimmt schon.
Und dann jemand hat ein schweres Kreuz zu tragen, sagt man gar nicht wiederum.
Null.
Nee.
Null, ganz, ganz selten.
Aber auf jeden Fall, ja, ganz schwierig.
Vielleicht müssen wir da echt nochmal in die Bibel gehen und wirklich gucken, was genau mit Kreuz gemeint ist, wo anatomisches Kreuz anfängt und wo aufhört.
Weil es ist ja schon wichtig symbolisch. Warum sagt man eigentlich, jeder hat sein Päckchen zu tragen? Das klingt nicht schwer. Nee, jeder hat sein Paket zu tragen. Das wäre was. Jeder hat sein Paket, ein ordentliches Paket zu tragen. Ja, aber Päckchen, jeder hat sein Beutelchen zu tragen. Jeder hat sein Kreuz zu tragen. Warum greift man dann dann nicht auf das eine Sprichwort zurück, was Sinn ergibt aus dem Christentum? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe mir auch vorgenommen, ich benutze keine Sprichwörter mehr, die ich nicht verstehe. Ich habe oft benutzt irgendwie so dieses Ein an der Kandarre haben oder so. Und wirklich, ich habe in meinem Leben noch nicht von der Kandarre gehört. Nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was es bedeutet. Und ich schaue auch immer in ganz leere Gesichter, wenn ich das sage. Weil die meisten Leute ja in der Regel davon ausgehen, dass sie selber dumm sind und dann einfach nicken und lächeln und einfach mitmachen. Deswegen kein Plan, was das bedeutet. Wie wir im Magazin Autorenraum. Eine Kandare, von Ungarisch Kantare, Zaumzeug, nennt man im Pferdesport ein nicht gebrochenes Gebissstück mit Hebelwirkungen.. Selbst die Erklärung steht. Von Kantare? Im Unterschied zu... Kantare, Kantare, oh oh, nee.
Volare heißt fliegen.
Volare heisst fliegen oder stehlen, man weiss es nicht genau.
Oh, jemand hat deinen Witz verstanden zum ersten Mal. Ja, endlich hat jemand meinen Witz verstanden.
Vielen, vielen Dank an alle, die mir geschrieben haben auf Instagram.
Es war eine ganze Menge.
Die Kommission ist hilarious.
Du sagst, jemand fragt dich, wie dein Französisch-Ernten-Lern-App heisst. Du sagst, XYZ kann ich sehr empfehlen, funktioniert sehr gut bei mir. Der andere sagt Merci, du sagst, was? Genau. Er sagt, Lachaugen-Emoji. Das hat gut funktioniert. Einige haben sich auch an verschiedenen Variationen versucht. In meinen Augen ist keine davon geglückt, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, aber ich bin zumindest froh, dass es ein paar Mal gut funktioniert hat. Und ich war auch treu, ich habe jedem genauso geantwortet und vielen, vielen Dank an alle, die geschrieben haben. Ihr habt mir sehr, sehr geholfen. Ab jetzt werde ich das nur noch so machen, dass, bevor ich Leute treffe, ich ihnen schon so Witzdrehbücher schicke, dass, wenn man sich dann trifft, man auch wirklich genau das Richtige sagen kann.
Ich habe hingegen eine Nachricht bekommen, dass es Stopp, Stefan, hör sofort auf mit dem, was du da machst, don't go there, du läufst ins offene Messer, ich soll lieber nicht mit einer englischsprachigen App Spanisch lernen. Wobei ich der Meinung bin, dass es mich nicht daran behindert, Spanisch zu lernen.
Also weil Englisch spricht man mittlerweile ja schon ganz okay so und das... Wobei ich der Meinung bin, es ist mich nicht wirklich daran behindert, Spanisch zu lernen.
Also weil Englisch spricht man mittlerweile ja schon ganz okay so und das ist dann jetzt auch kein Hindernis irgendwie. Aber dann merke ich, dass wenn ich Spanisch spreche, gerade, also in den seltenen Fällen, fallen mir die Wörter nicht gut ein. Ich meine, was ist das Schlimmste, das passieren kann? Manche Leute schreiben dann wirklich so Mails mit ganz viel Capslog und wirklich so, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Was ist das Schlimmste, das passieren kann? Manche Leute schreiben dann wirklich so Mails mit ganz viel
Capslog und wirklich so, nein, auf gar keinen
Fall. Was ist das Schlimmste, was passieren kann?
Dass du vielleicht leicht falsch
Spanisch lernst oder zu wenig. Ich meine,
sind wir ehrlich, du gibst in zwei Wochen eh wieder auf.
Ich meine, wie lange hast du Japanisch gelernt?
Ich will jetzt dir nicht zu nahe treten,
aber du bist halt ein sehr willensschwacher,
weicher Mensch, der
das, was dich vornimmt, in der
Regel nicht durchzieht. Letztens
hast du, am Set habe ich dich
Vielen Dank. Aber du bist halt ein sehr willensschwacher, weicher Mensch, der das, was er dich vornimmt, in der Regel nicht durchzieht. Letztens hast du, am Set habe ich dich reden hören, darüber, welches Schlagzeug du dir kaufen willst. Ich weiß nicht, was daraus geworden ist, ich habe dich dann aber nochmal in ganz peinlicher Stille erinnert an eine Posaune, die du gekauft hast, wo du zweimal irgendwie den Hogwarts-March posaunt hast und dann aber auch wieder aufgehört hast. Stimmt, ich bin ein Hogwarts-March posaunt. Wie liefst du ein Schlagzeug? Erzähl doch mal, was hast du auf dem Schlagzeug schon gespielt? Hast du da schon Whip-Lash gespielt? Nee, ich habe es mir noch nicht gekauft. Aber es gibt, genau, weil du hast gesagt, du willst dir sowas kaufen und am Tag danach habe ich dieses Start-up gesehen von diesen Schlägeln, die so ein ganzes Schlagzeug imitieren. Man hat aber nur die Schläge, sonst gar nichts. Das ist ärgerlich, wenn man für sehr viel Geld ein Schlagzeug kauft, ein E-Schlagzeug, und dann einen Tag danach bei Kickstarter die Sticks, die aus allem ein Schlagzeug machen, gelauncht werden. Genau. Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert, aber anscheinend können die dann in der Luft Widerstand geben. Ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert, aber die Models in dem Kickstarter-Video sahen auf jeden Fall begeistert aus. Sagen fantastisch aus. Das kann nicht gespielt sein. Schöne Menschen lügen nicht, das bestelle ich auf jeden Fall. Das war so ein Kickstarter irgendwie so, wir wollen 80.000 Euro und die hatten 2,3 Millionen. Also wirklich so komplett drüber einfach. Kriegt man das Geld dann eigentlich wieder, als jemand den gespendelt hat? Ich glaube nicht, du kriegst dann diese Stöcke. er hat gesagt, okay, unser Ziel wurde tausendfach erreicht, die Stöcke können jetzt auch noch in der Zeit reisen, so drei Minuten.
Deshalb konnten wir uns noch draufpacken, weil wir hatten zu viel Geld und dann haben wir einfach oben draufgelegt.
So die sind jetzt grün.
Ja genau, davor konnten wir uns nur blau leisten, die billigste Farbe, jetzt ist aber grün mit drin. Ja die teuerste Farbe, ein mattes Grün und es war die teuerste Farbe, die wir bekommen konnten. Und der einfachste Weg, um den Preis zu legitimieren einigermassen. Aber hat da mal eine Kickstarter-Kampagne gesagt, ja, jetzt sind wir pleite. Weil die 2,3 Millionen, die er uns gegeben hat für das Produkt, haben wir verloren. Ich glaube schon, da gibt es immer wieder Skanade. Die haben wir gespendet und dann den Rest verloren. Dann haben wir leider vergessen. An wen? Und jetzt müssen wir leider los. Gehen. Ciao. So ganz langsam. Love you. Genau, es erscheint so ganz langsam. Es gibt ja so Leute, die WhatsApp-Nachrichten so Wort für Wort abschicken. Und das sind so Nachrichten, die so Buchstabe für Buchstabe abgeschickt werden. So, wir müssen euch was mitteilen, dass irgendwie 670 neue Nachrichten. An geschriebener Sprache ist ja auch, dass man sich nicht gut ins Wort fallen kann, dachte ich, aber kann man auch.
Das habe ich jetzt gerade, wenn man sich nicht gut ins Wort fallen kann, dachte ich, aber kann man auch.
Das habe ich jetzt gerade, wenn man halt längere Gespräche führt über WhatsApp, so unangenehme Klärgespräche, Streitgespräche, was auch immer,
wo man schon merkt, an der Länge der einzelnen Nachricht, hier wird gerade was verhandelt, hier geht es gerade um was, eh eine gute Faustregel,
je länger die durchschnittliche Nachricht eines Textes, desto wichtiger das Gespräch. Und dann kann man sich schon ins Wort fallen. Weil dann tippt man gerade noch und ich finde, man muss den anderen oben austippen lassen. Da bin ich ganz streng. Genau, das ist nämlich auch so das Ding, manchmal passiert es mir, dass die andere Person schreibt und ich schreibe auch. Und dann weiss ich, oh, die andere Person sieht jetzt, dass ich schreibe, ich sehe, dass sie schreibt, beide schreiben, beide hören auf zu schreiben und dann tagelang nichts, einfach nichts mehr. Wir beide wissen, dass die andere Person jeweils etwas mitteilen wollte, aber wir sind wirklich in so einem so Pluspol, Pluspol, es geht nicht weiter, so es funktioniert einfach nicht, über Tage hinweg, es hat Leute seit Monaten nichts geschrieben, wo die letzte Kontakt war, man schreibt gleichzeitig, oh, er, sie will gerade was schreiben, man hört auf, aus. Klar, aber du musst eineinitiative ergreifen, aber prinzipiell finde ich es sehr unterstützungswert, zu sagen, fallt euch nicht ins Wort, auch beim Schreiben. Ich habe es nämlich jetzt neulich gemacht, ich habe geschrieben und dann hat die andere Person geschrieben, aber jetzt möchte ich nicht mehr sagen, was ich schreiben wollte. Ich habe es schon geschrieben, jetzt hast du was geschrieben und jetzt kann ich nicht mehr das sagen, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte. Und dann dachte ich mir, ah, das ist jetzt, jetzt macht man sich selbst das kaputt, was es ja als Vorteil hat noch. Hat ja nicht viele Vorteile, so nonverbale Kommunikation. Wobei man ja auch Next Level werden kann und also der Chatter von heute benutzt ja nicht nur ein Chatting-App, sondern mehrere.
Und du kannst ja immer, wenn das Gespräch auf WhatsApp an der Wand gelaufen ist, kannst du immer noch auf Telegram von der Seite, von der rechten Flanke, irgendwie mit so einem Hundesticker, nochmal komplett einen neuen Weg aufmachen. Es gibt tatsächlich Kontakte, die Leute, mit denen ich auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen, auf unterschiedlichen Apps schreibe. Also wirklich auf WhatsApp wirklich nur Serious Business, so wir treffen uns da und da und da, auf Telegram nur Hundebilder.
Ja, weil WhatsApp ja auch der seriöse Messenger ist. Na klar. Und auf Trema wirklich nur so tiefgründige, philosophische Gespräche tief nachts. So das ist wirklich was anderes. Streamer schreibe ich nur mit, oder Tremer schreibe ich nur mit Investigativjournalisten.
Und sie erärgen.
Auf WhatsApp schreibe ich nur mit Investigativjournalisten. Und sie erärgen. Und sie erärgen.
Auf WhatsApp
schreibe ich mit den meisten Leuten
und auf iMessage schreibe ich noch mit.
Wie zum Beispiel, wir sind, du bist
der einzige Grupp in meinem
Alter, mit dem ich über iMessage kommuniziere.
Okay, ansonsten nur Jüngere, oder wie?
Ne, deutlich ältere. Ach so.
Zum Beispiel mein
Chef, der Producer der Serie, Philipp und ein Kollege von uns, ein älterer Autorenkollege. Mit denen schreibe ich jeweils auf iMessage, weil das sind so, aber auch nur aus Gefallen. Das haben die beiden mal irgendwann gehört, dass ich das für die mache und sonst nicht da kommuniziere. Und dann waren die ein bisschen beleidigt, weil die sich dann alt fühlen. Weil ich nur für die dann diesen Messenger wechsle.
Das ist wie so eine, weiß ich nicht, Gehhilfe. Wenn du so den Morse-Apparat noch beibehältst und sagst, gut, Ommer Morse, komm ab und zu nochmal durch. Komm, komm, von mir aus. Von mir aus machen wir es da. Soll es verstehen. Und du bist der andere Kontakt, den ich da schreibe. Das ist nett. Weil neulich hast du mir auf WhatsApp geschrieben, da habe ich mich ganz verwundert. Da fand ich auch dann irgendwie, da bin ich so gefühlt hat man manchmal, wenn man morgens noch nicht darauf geeicht ist, mit Leuten zu reden, und zum Beispiel beim Bäcker steht. Der Bäcker ist der erste Mensch, mit dem man morgens spricht. Und plötzlich steht so ein Kollege neben einem und sagt so ganz frisch, guten Morgen, hi! Und man ist schon so, man ist noch gar nicht in dem Ansprechmodus. Nee, das darf man nicht machen. Nee, voll. So, aber genauso habe ich mich gefühlt, wie du mich dann bei WhatsApp plötzlich angeschrieben hast, weil man da, das war so eine Safe Zone, also da bin ich nicht einfach nicht gewohnt mit jetzt, also das ist nicht schlecht. Ja, stimmt schon, ja, ich bin eingedrungen in eine Safe Zone von dir. Ja, da stand ich plötzlich da. Da ist Florentin nicht. Genau, das ist plötzlich, wenn du mit deinen coolen Freunden unterwegs bist und plötzlich tauche ich auf und hallo, hey, ich bin jetzt auch auf WhatsApp, ich habe gesehen, wann ihr euch trefft. Ah, hallo. Bei Telegram ist es zumindest schön, dass man diese Nachricht bekommt, XY ist jetzt auch bei Telegram. Ja, genau. So das ist so ein kurzes Alert, so ein, ja, er hat den Raum betreten. Das ist so schön wie bei einer Party abends, man weiß jetzt auch da. Genau, aber es ist auch ein bisschen so ein unangenehmes Schweigen. Ich habe mir letztens beigetreten, Blablaka Tobias ist Telegram beigetreten. Okay, jetzt aber. Jetzt, wie kann man diesen Kontakt noch retten? Was haben wir da gemeinsam? Wir haben nicht geredet, Minus, Minus, bei Blabla hatten wir damals. Wenn eine unbekannte Nummer anruft, speichere ich mir die mal ein als Vorname unbekannt, Nachname, das Datum, zum Beispiel heute wäre es dann der, weiß ich nicht, 22.9. sowas. Und dann speichere ich die so ein, damit ich bei WhatsApp das Profilbild angucken kann. Bei WhatsApp das Profilbild ist ja dann oft aussagekräftig, wer das gerade ist. Ja. Wobei mir die Nummer nicht so viel sagt. So, das mache ich immer. Stefan. Und deswegen, das passiert so, weil so jeden Tag tritt unbekannt 0708 bei Telegram dabei. Und ich bin immer kurz davor, den zu schreiben. Du bist in einem Raum voller fremder Leute, aber du weißt nicht, wohin. Ja, das ist ein Raum voller Leute, die man alle schon mal gesehen hat, aber nicht zuordnen kann. Ich bin der schlechteste, was Organisationen von Kontakten angeht. Ich habe zum Beispiel, glaube ich, locker elf Tobis bei mir in der Liste. Und wenn irgendwann mal dieser schwarze Tag in meiner Zukunft kommt, wenn ich Tobi anrufen muss, hätte ich durchschnittlich gesehen vier, fünf falsche Tobis anrufen müssen. Wenn ich den Nachnamen nicht weise, immer Tobi beruf. Ja, ich weiß, das ist schlau, aber ich bin wirklich, ich denke nie voraus, ich denke nicht in die
Zukunft. Tobi Tonmann. Ich denke immer, Tobi, egal,
schnell, ich muss weitermachen, ich muss weiterkommen,
ich muss rennen, ich will in Bewegung bleiben,
ich will jetzt nicht in die Zukunft denken,
sondern das kriege ich dann schon irgendwann hin.
Und da hatte ich tatsächlich schon
diese Zyklen, wo man anruft
und dann, hi,
ja, Isabel, ja, hi, Florentin hier, wer, gut, dann hat sich das schon erledigt, tschau, und dann, ja Isi hier, ja hi, Florentin hier, auch aufgelegt direkt,fach furchtbar, bis man da kommt.
Ja, das stimmt schon, aber man freut sich manchmal, wenn man in der Vergangenheit schlau war, freut man sich so sehr über seine Vergangenheit.
Ja, ja. Da steht halt wie Tobi Tonmann und dann einfach noch eine Firma dahinter oder so.
Manchmal schreibe ich sogar, ein Nachwarn bei mir ist in der Liste, kenne ich von hm, weil es so um zwei Ecken ein Kumpel ist, Tobi, kenne ich von Anna, und dann ruft er an, das wird nicht passieren. Und du kannst über Anna reden, hast du das mit Anna gesehen? Das ist das Nächste, wenn du dir reinschreibst, oh, Mutter ist letztens gestorben, oder Tobi hat jetzt ja das Schlagzeug, wenn du dir schon so Smalltalk-Hilfen in den Anrufer reinlegst. Man bräuchte eigentlich so eine Art Sekretär, der einem wirklich so soziale Sachen aufbereitet, der ihm wirklich wie so ein Dossier gibt. Aber ist Siri nicht einfach schlecht in ihrem Job? Ja, also wirklich, die hat schon lange keine Gehaltserhöhung von mir bekommen, die ist irgendwie... Siri hängt da rum und lackiert sich ihre Fingernägel, muss man ganz ehrlich mal sagen. Es braucht da mal ein ernstes Mitarbeitergespräch, wo ich sage, Siri, wenn Sie zu mir in ein Zimmer kommen, dann an völlig unpassenden Momenten, wo ich Sie nicht gerufen habe, und wenn ich Sie rufe, dann kommen Sie tagelang nicht und erzählen mir dann irgendwelche Sachen, die ich hören will. Ich weiß nicht, welche Tasten ich hier drücken muss, damit sie in mein Zimmer kommen. Ehrlich gesagt, wirklich nicht.
Aber immer wenn, dann ungefragt einfach plötzlich rein, auch mitten in unerhörigen Situationen oder Gespräche auch so rein oder sowas. Und sie antworten nicht auf meine Fragen. Aber ich glaube, es gibt eine Person, bei der ich manchmal bin, die so Spracherkennungs Siri-Google-Ding hat. Und nichts macht mir so viel Spaß, wie dieser Google-Button, wie das Ding zu brechen, einfach zu versuchen, wie weit kann man es treiben. Also wirklich, was ist der Punkt, wo du sagst, jetzt fick dich mal, okay? Halt deine Hüfte! Wirklich, wenn du einfach sagst, also erst mal zu gucken, was die Spracherkennung kann. Also erst mal, okay, Nudel, okay, Pude, okay, Rudel, okay, Doodle. Ich weiß, dass bei ganz vielen Leuten das jetzt angeht. Und dann einfach so was wie so Captain Oetker. Und einfach mal Captain Oetker sagen und dann rattern, ratter, ratter, ratter. Dazu habe ich keine Ergebnisse gefunden, mit den Tränen nahe. Und dann wirklich so, Doktor Iglu. Meinten sie bestehend? Thorsten Gottschalk. Wer war Thorsten Gottschalk? Weil sie weiss ja, wen man meint.
Genau, ja.
Aber ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, Google ist nicht so erst mal nicht so freundlich und nicht so schlagfertig wie Alexa. Nee, aber ich einfach so Alter, Keanu Cruz. Fick dich! Lass mich in Ruhe! Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ben, wen vermeint du meinst. Was ich auch mal gerne mache, ist Rezept Hotdog. Nimm ein Brötchen, leg eine Wurst rein. Einfach so Rezept von Chefkoch.de, Hotdog, Brötchen und dann einfach so ein Hotdog-Rezept. So ganz lächerlich einfach.
Aber das macht mir richtig viel Freude.
Das ist im Grunde einfach das, was man als Kind so irgendwie so einen Vogel quälen, der irgendwie aus dem Nest gefallen ist.
So quält man heute, kann man einfach Technik quälen.
Das Schöne ist, es tut jetzt niemandem weh.
Außer es ist einfach eine Horde Inder.
Könnte auch sein, dass ein Raum Inder einfach sagt, ich kündige, ich breche hier zusammen.
Ich weiß nicht, was diese Person von mir will.
Vielen Dank. Das ist einfach eine Horde Inder. Könnte auch sein, dass ein Raum Inder einfach sagt, ich kündige, ich breche hier zusammen, ich weiß nicht, was diese Person von mir will. Er hat schon wieder Kjell-O-Cruz gesagt. Und die Kamera zoomt so raus und es ist so ein Inder, der aufgestanden ist in so einem Raum, wie bei Indiana Jones hinten. Ja, genau. Und es sind immer mehr Inder, es kommen immer mehr Inder, so ein Riesenraum. Ja, wo in einem Grossraumbüro so ein grosses Bild von mir ist, wie ich so mir die Hände reibe und so böse lache. Ja, want it. Wenn du immer mal nach Indien kommst, du bist auf offener Strasse einfach ermorchelt. Ich glaube aber, dass es normal ist. Ich glaube, das ist das meiste, was diese Spracherkennungsdinge machen. Die Person, Jeff Goldum hat sich das wahrscheinlich so gedacht, ja, damit wird die Welt
revolutioniert und die Leute müssen keine Hände mehr
benutzen und so. Aber was am Ende passiert,
ist einfach nur Nonsens. Wie sehr kann man
die brechen? Hot-Lock-Rezept. Schnell.
Alter Keanu-Beef.
Rezepte gefunden.
Ist Keanu eigentlich der einzige, der Keanu heißt mit
Vornamen? Ich glaube schon. Auf eine Art auch cool.
Ja, Keanu?
... Rezepte gefunden. Ist Keanu eigentlich der einzige, der Keanu heißt mit Vornamen? Ich glaube schon. Auf eine Art auch cool. Ja, Keanu? Keanu? Bestimmt glaube ich, wie die Kinder Keanu nennen. Ich bin ein großer Fan von einem Formel-1-Fahrer, der heisst Lando Norris. Und der wurde, der ist so, keine Ahnung, 19 Jahre alt oder sowas, und der wurde Lando genannt, wie Lando Carissian. Mega gut. Aber nicht wegen Lando Carissian, weil seine Mutter, die den Namen sich auch gesagt hat, kannte den Film nicht. Ja. Der ist einfach Lando. Wir haben eine Mail bekommen, du hast keinen Namen. Wir haben eine Mail bekommen, ich verändere den Nachnamen, aber wo ich mir auch dachte, fantastisch, da haben die Eltern wirklich mitgedacht, der hieß Georg Lucas Schneider. Der ist Georg Lucas, einfach so ein Doppelname. Und wenn du George Lucas als Vorname heisstisst, ist das einfach genial. Einfach wie George Michael bei Arrested Development, der einfach George Michael heisst, als Vorname. Das ist einfach fantastisch. George Michael Blue. Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir geht, aber ich habe eine Abneigung gegen Menschen, wo der Nachname ein Vorname ist. Ja. Also ich kenne. Du weißt nicht, wie rum, oder was?
Erstmal, in meinem Kopf verwechsele ich das andauernd
und ich weiss nie, wie rum.
Und ich muss immer erst überlegen, bevor ich den Namen sage.
Ist es eigene Dummheit und so?
Es ist immer so, ich weiß nicht,
mir ist noch keiner begegnet, mit dem ich sofort
connecte, dessen
Nachname ein Vorname ist. Glaubst du, das ist automatisch
eine Identitätskrise, wenn du so heisst? Ich glaube schon. Ich meine, George Lucas, sein Sohn Lucas Lucas, das ist schwierig, damit umzugehen. Das ist einfach, man weiß es nicht genau, wie man damit leben kann. George Lucas, George Michael, George Lucas, ihr Kind soll George Lucas Lucas heißen? Ja, Lord Jukas. Lord Jukas Lukas der Zweite. Nee, das finde ich schwierig. Aber jetzt schreibt nicht alle, wenn ihr irgendwie Markus mit Namen heisst. Nein, ihr seid tolle Menschen. Ihr seid ganz, ganz toll. Ich kenne auch mal Familie Stefan, das war auch weird einfach. Dann war man halt da, bei Familie Stefan zuhause. Da fühlt man sich nicht gut.
Das ist ein unangenehmes Gefühl, aber man muss sich merken. Da muss man dann halt einfach durchbeissen. Man muss manchem im Leben durch unangenehme Situationen einfach durch. Werbung Seid ihr auf der Suche nach neuen Laptops, einem Weggefährten, der euch über
den ganzen Tag redet und nicht schon nach zwei Stunden komplett lehrt? Werbung Podcast, aber das geht mir zu weit. Gibt es wirklich die Dell XPS-Modelle? Ja, Florent, du brauchst mich gar nicht so angucken mit deinen kleinen Augen. 13, 15 und 17 Zoll Modelle gibt es und die müsst ihr euch wirklich mal angucken. Das sind die XPS-Modelle von Dell und die haben dank neuer modernster Technologie einen Akku, der wirklich länger hält als ein ganzer Arbeitstag. Da übertreibe ich jetzt nicht.
Der dann einfach nur lange Akku-Aufzeit und sonst nichts, oder was? Nein, der hat auch ein einzigartiges Design, denn die neu definierten Infinity-Edge-Displays und die diamantgeschliffenen Seitenwände, die Handauflage aus hochwertiger Carbonfaser, machen das ganz zu einem echten Hingucker. Zusätzlich könnt ihr dank neuster der Mobile-Connect-Technologie auch eure Handys, auch mit IOS-Betriebssystem oder Android, Smartphone, wie auch immer,
connecten und auch über das Laptop, über den Schlepptop SMS versenden oder iMessages.
Das ist echt cool.
Würdest du sagen, Dell hat den Schlepptop revolutioniert?
Ich würde sagen, Dell hat zum Bleistift den Schlepptop revolutioniert.
Ich glaube, das würden die so nicht formulieren, aber im Grunde ist es so.
Im Grunde ist es so, sie trauen sich nichts zu sagen. Dell, auf die Details kommt es an. Werbung. Bist du eher so ein, du trittst aus deinem Körper raus oder du beißt dich durch in unangenehmen Situationen oder wie machst du es? Was ist deine Strategie? Ich beiß mich durch und ich versuche dann auch, ich glaube, man würde es mir nie ansehen, wenn ich eine schlechte Situation habe unbedingt.
Außer ich habe auch aufgegeben oder mir geht es wirklich sehr schlecht, aber normalerweise versuche ich durch zu faken. Deswegen denke ich mir auch immer so, wenn ich ein sehr unangenehmes Gespräch habe, stelle ich mir oft danach die Frage, war das für das Gegenüber jetzt auch so unangenehm? Und in den meisten Fällen glaube ich nicht, weil ich schon immer so spiele, als wäre alles in Ordnung und so. Und selbst wenn du ganz wenig zurückkommst, bei mir ist immer Full Energy, lachend geht die Welt zugrunde, wirklich ganz euphorisch bin ich noch und wie so ein Geiger auf der Titanic. Das Gespräch ist schon lange untergegangen und ich versuche noch umzuperformen und so und ich weiß schon, das wird alles nicht funktionieren. Bis ich um die Ecke bin, bin ich, was auch so ein schlechtes Date oder so, ich bin bis zum Ende, haha, ist doch alles super, lustig, haha, um die Ecke und ich breche zusammen, breche Wein zusammen, kann nicht mehr, muss erst mal einen Liter trinken, und so. Jeder Gag schmettert einfach ab, jeder, nee, aber das spricht man eigentlich ganz anders aus. Oh mein Gott. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man darüber Witze machen sollte. Das nach zwei Minuten Date einfach so.
Okay, das wird... anders aus. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man darüber Witze machen sollte.
Das nach zwei Minuten Date einfach so.
Okay, das wird unangenehm.
Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, ja.
Nee, aber ich habe jetzt wieder,
ich habe jetzt schon wieder Locken.
Ich wurde von meinem Umfeld
dazu genötigt, alle hassen
jetzt nur die glatten Haare, das war jetzt
ein bisschen doof. Ich habe es dir gesagt,
als du deine Transformation gemacht hast,
vom hässlichen Entlein, vom hässlichen
In Titzlein hin zu einem strahlenden Schwan, habe ich gesagt, Stefan, pass auf, die Leute werden dich später nicht mehr für das mögen, was du bist, sondern nur noch dich als strahlenden Schwan sehen. Und die werden nicht mehr akzeptieren, wenn du irgendwann dann mit einem Garfield-T-Shirt irgendwo aufkreuz und einfach mal du selbst sein willst.
Nein, die werden dich nie wieder für das sehen, was du bist. Du hast gesagt, nein, geh mir aus dem Weg, hast mich aus deinem Porsche geschmissen und bist mit quietschen Reifen davon gefahren, direkt in die Polizeikontrolle. Ja, genau. Aber gut, du hast jetzt die Locken als Teil von dir. Das ist ein Teil von mir. Ja, ich würde ein bisschen so sagen wie du vielleicht auch einfach, dachte ich auch. Oh, auch interessant. Naja, und dann habe ich wieder acht Stunden beim Friseur gesessen und habe mir mit pinken Lockenbeglein natürlich Locken machen lassen. Und das Spannende ist aber, weil anders als eine Tönung, ich habe jetzt auch einen Kumpel, der hat sich die Haare platinblond gefärbt, ist gerade offensichtlich ein ein Trend, da sieht es halt danach, irgendwann denkt man, ah, sieht scheiße aus, man sieht aber auch warum, weil der Ansatz halt rauskommt, weil die braunen Haare nachkommen. Du siehst, warum scheiße aussieht. Wenn Locken rauswachsen, ist es immer so ein, du siehst einfach scheiße aus, weil man kann es nicht zuordnen, weil man diesen Anblick nicht kennt. Also du hast keine Locken mehr so richtig, weil die rausgewachsen sind, weil diese Lockenflüssigkeit weird verblechen ist. Nee, ich glaube, die Struktur kommt einfach wieder, keine Ahnung. Und dann ist aber auch der Ansatz rausgewachsen, in der gleichen Farbe, aber halt glatt. Du hast so leicht stroigere Haare, also du hast so sehr voluminöse, irgendwie sieht es einfach scheiße aus, aber man kann es nicht zuordnen. Ich prophezeie einfach mal die nächste Stefan-Phase, und zwar, ich glaube, wir erleben eine Hutphase. Wir erleben eine Hutphase, ich glaube, keine Capphase, sondern wirklich eine Hutphase. Hasse Hüte. Ich hasse auch Hüte, aber ich glaube, das kommt noch. Auf gar keinen Fall. Ich glaube, es fängt erst an mit Mützen und dann irgendwann gewöhnst du dich daran, an die erstmal schönen Beanies, dann gewöhnst du dich an den Komfort, dass du dich nicht um deine Haare kümmern musst, und dann kommt irgendwie so ein Hut. Und wirklich so ein ganz kleiner erst mal. Die wird immer grösser, bis immer so ein ausladender Sombrero wird oder so ein Captain Barbossa. Oh ja, genau. Doktor Barbossa? Wer war Doktor Barbossa? Bachelor of Arts Barbarossa, man weiß es nicht genau. Viele Leute haben uns übrigens geschickt, womit sie alles schon durchgekommen sind bei Post. Es gab eine, die hat uns einen Brief geschickt, Bachelor of Arts und dann ihr Name war auf jeden Fall möglich, beim Brief anzugeben. Aber es gibt anscheinend viele Leute, die damit grossen Spaß haben. Und ich glaube auch, dass die Post das mit dem Spunzler. Konsul. Zweiter Konsul. Markise. Markese. Ja, Baron, sowas. Erzherzog. Gibt es Baron noch? Nee, Graf gibt es noch. Wir wollten in der letzten Staffel bei einem Graf drehen. Und dann musste ein Filmteam von uns, also ein kleines Team, den Grafen kennenlernen. Und der Graf hat dann durch seineereien, ist mit denen so rumgewandert.
Das gehört alles mir, hat er so ein Monokel im Ohr gesagt. Ganz merkwürdige. Comedy-Graf. Merkwürdige. Graf Hilarius. Ich bin ja mit einem Graf zur Schule gegangen. Wir hatten einen Graf in unserer Klasse und der tatsächlich auch in seinem Ausweis stehen hatte,
so und so, Graf von so und so, stand wirklich in seinem Ausweis drin und der hat anscheinend auch in einem
krassen Anwesen gewohnt, mit Ritterrüstung
in dem Keller und so, also richtig. Aber für dich als
Straight-Lighter-Fan. Ich bin da noch nicht hingekommen,
das war einer der coolsten Typen der ganzen
Scheche. War der cool? Natürlich war der cool.
Naja, eher uncool. Der wurde regelmäßig
von unserer Deutschlehrerin gefragt, sagen Sie mal, wie ist das denn eigentlich, wenn man weiß, dass man ausgesorgt hat, dass man nicht arbeiten muss? Und dieser 17-jährige Typ halt, ja, keine Ahnung, ist halt schon geil, aber was soll ich dazu jetzt sagen? Aber die Lehrerin, die da wirklich so tief links dann immer so, na aber wie ist es denn, also einfach mal zu wissen, dass man mehr Geld hat als die anderen. Ich weiß nicht, was die von dem erwartet hat, dass sie jetzt sagt, ja irgendwie. Natürlich. Jetzt hier haben sie 10.000 Euro, ja gut, ist gut. Aber war eigentlich immer ganz, keine Ahnung, war irgendwie weird. Wie spannend. Aber der stand auch irgendwie so raus aus allen. Also dieses Adels, glaube ich. Aber sah der auch so aus, war der so ein blonder, schöner? Eigentlich nicht, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der war, ja, Prin, so eine Art Prinz. Der hatte halt auch schon normale Kleidung an, der hatte halt immer so ein Säbel an der Seite, aber ansonsten eigentlich ganz normal. Also der fällt nicht groß auf, wenn man jetzt wirklich nur von oben betrachtet. Gut, die Pfauenfeder hat halt, aber nur an Feiertagen. Das sind natürlich schon die zwei Diener, die hinter ihm hergelaufen sind und dem Luftzug gefächelt haben, ja. Aber das war schon ... Genau, wie ja Kim Jong-un in die Schweiz zur Schule gegangen ist und immer zwei, dann im Nachhinein so Leute für Dokus befragt wurden, die dann auch wahrscheinlich nicht nur eine Dokus, sondern tausende Nordkorea-Dokus und irgendwann auch bei der Tausendsten Dokus dann so, ja, nein, ich habe nicht gemerkt,
dass Kim Jong-Un bei uns auf der Schule
war, immer genervter, von Dokus zu danken.
So das Klassenfoto, immer Zoom auf das Gesicht.
Hatte denn wirklich niemand
gemerkt, mit wem sie sich dort ein Klassenzimmer
teilten? Nein, nein,
die sind die Tausendste Doku.
Die Klasse besteht aus,
wie viel haben Sie denn über Ihre Klassikammeraden
gewusst?
Ich lese ja auch gerade, jetzt langsam quäle ich mich durch dieses Napoleon-Buch. Immer noch. Immer noch, ja, ja, der hatte ein Leben. Na ja, ich bin jetzt erst bei der Jugendzeit. Ja, kann sein, aber wenn du dir denkst, okay, ich bin Jugend, ich bin auf Seite 50 von 1200, da muss noch was kommen. Und auf jeden Fall krass, weil der wurde ja, der kam ja aus Korsika ursprünglich und hat erst gar kein Französisch gesprochen, sondern Italienisch, kam dann nach Frankreich und wurde dann von allen so ein bisschen gemobbt, weil der war ja so auf einer Militärschule relativ früh. Und er wurde dann von allen gemobbt, weil er halt kein Französisch richtig gesprochen hat und halt klarer Aussenseiter war.
Wo ich mir auch dachte, wie haben die Leute, die Napoleon in der Schule gemobbt haben, sich später gefühlt, als sie einfach ganz Europa beherrscht hat und immer so sich dachten so Scheiße, Scheiße, hoffentlich kommt da nicht, klopft da nicht mal irgendjemand an einfach so. Aber auf der anderen Seite fühlt es sich vielleicht auch gut an, dass du einfach der warst, der eine der mächtigsten Personen der Weltgeschichte gemobbt hast einfach und du kennst ihn noch als irgendwie Nappi, den du irgendwie in den Spind eingeschlossen hast oder so und der sich nicht wehren konnte. Nappi, Nappi, Boni, Boni, Boni, Boni, Boni kommst du her. Der hat dann auch seinen Namen geändert, von Bonaparte zu Buonaparte. Steht bei Wikipedia auch Bonaparte gestorben als Buonaparte. Oh cool.
Ist auch, wo man sich auch überlegt, wann genau dieser Punkt kommt.
Bei mir wird gestorben als Tietze mit I-E. Genauso wäre es auch bei dir. Wenn ich dann mit 18 sterbe, 28 sterbe, einem tragischen Flugzeugunglück, wie wir alle wissen, dann mit Tietze. Genau, gestorben, Tietze, über, wie he es, über, also so, wie heißt es das Gebiet im Meer, wo niemand das sagen hat.
Ich verlieh Vokabeln sekündlich, wo niemand weiß, was machen muss. Je mehr Französisch du lernst, desto mehr Deutsch wird auch weggeschoben.
Natürlich, was denkst du denn?
Schmeiss alles raus. Wie heisst das Herrschafts- No man's land, halt einfach da, wo niemand mal was ansagt. Da, wo niemand den Hut auf hat. So Hochheitswasser, mein Gott. Hochwasser. Nein, nicht Hochwasser, aber halt. Nee, ich weiß. Herrschaftsho ... Ohne ... Keine Herrschaftsgebiet. Halt. Ohne Herrn Lender, halt einfach ... Da, wo niemand ... Wasserhoch ... Zuhause ist. Meereshoheit. Land der Meerjungmänner und Frauen. Meereshoheit. Meereshöhe. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nee, Seevölkerrecht. Herrscher, hohe, mohe, moheiz, nee, verdammt doch mal. Okay, und wenn ihr dacht, es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als die Orbum-Folge, dann war es die Folge, wo sie sich auf das Wort gekommen. 40 Minuten lang das Wort Hoheizgewässer. Hoheizgewässer, na ja. Ja? Stefan Tze, geboren, kamen. Territorialgewässer. Stefan Tietze, gestorben, Hoheitsgewässer. Ich würde gerne Salvador oder sowas. Ich würde wirklich in so einem luftleeren Raum sterben. Das ist leicht machbar. Er ist in einem Vakuum gestorben. In einem kontextlosen Luftlehrer Vakuum. Und einfach, wo man nicht weiß, wo man ihn begraben soll. Oder jemand, der wirklich zwischen auf dem Weg von der Erde zum Saturn, auf dem Weg will ich sterben. So dass niemand genau weiß. Aber dann eben an Corona oder so. An so einem leichten Schnupfen, an so einem rostigen Nagel irgendwie in meiner...
Haben Sie da reingefasst? Warum hängt die ein rostiger Nagel in the first place?
Das ist jetzt der zweitausendste Reisende. Das muss schon sein.
Oh, übrigens auf Netflix, schau gerade jetzt die Doku zur Challenger, hier diese Rakete, die explodiert ist, wo man sich auch denkt, puh, gibt die Geschichte so viel her?
Ich meine, die fliegen hoch, explodieren, aber dann ging es halt noch um die Leute, wer das war. Und dann eine Folge geht wieder trotzdem um Maddie McCann, die irgendwie verschwunden. Genau, irgendwie dann auch, der hatte eh Probleme. Oh, das ist aber auch spannend, dass es da jetzt weitergeht bei Maddie McCann. Haben wir noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen, weil es auch in unsere Pause fiel so ein bisschen. Aber jetzt haben die ja, ist ja ein Deutscher. Madeline. Also ich als deutscher Fan dieses Falls habe jetzt die gleiche Genugtuung, dass es jetzt diese, das ist jetzt eine Deutschlandstaffel. Genau, man denkt sich, jetzt endlich keine Untertitel mehr, endlich nicht mehr dieses scheiß Portugiesisch, sondern endlich wird es so einer schönen Deutschen. Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich so. Können die ganze scheiß Portugieser mal gucken, wie sie die Untertitel angucken, zwei Staffeln lang. Es gab bei Homeland diese Deutschlandstaffel. Ja. Und man sich irgendwie freut, weil man sieht, erkennt manchmal Dinge, jetzt werde ich bald wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Hannover in der Made in McCann Staffel zwei sehen. Ja. Wenigstens noch von The Staircase, die andere tolle True Crime Doku, da ging es ja auch schon nach Deutschland. Der deutsche Austauschstudent, da war doch ein Austauschstudent, während er gestorben ist. Hat man sich mal und du so yes, der war es doch, oder? Sprich deutsch, sprich deutsch, sprich deutsch. Yes, and then we, oh Gott. And then we went there. Ja. Ist dir mal aufgefallen, dass Deutsche in Serien, also wenn man Deutsche porträtiert, die immer schlecht Englisch sprechen, immer noch, ganz doll.
Ja.
Es ist nie, wenn man, oder so einen starken, oft schlechten, bei von Engländern oder Amerikanern gespielten deutschen Akzent.
Das ist immer sehr übertrieben. Klingt meist Russisch auch, aber es wird nie, niemand spricht gutes Englisch.
Das ist schon immer noch so, oder? Merkt man ja auch.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, wenn man mit Holländern spricht oder so was, oder Holländer ist, dann wird es schon besser Englisch gesprochen.
Ja, kann natürlich auch sein, dass man es dann auch übertreiben muss, weil man dann sagt, okay, es muss sofort ankommen, dass du Deutscher bist.
Genau. Und dann wird es noch dramaturgisch überhöht oder können Deutsche immer noch kein Englisch sprechen.
Würde ich aber auch machen tatsächlich. Also wenn ich mit einem englischsprachigen Muttersprachler reden würde, ich würde erst anfangen mit einem extrem starken Akzent, um dann im Laufe des Gesprächs den möglichst abzulegen, damit der andere denkt, wow, du hast wirklich viel, you really want to learn something sehr. Und dann sage ich thank you, oder thank you. Und dann bin ich total da, einfach so es ver verändern, weil jetzt, wenn wir Sprachen lernen, ich weiß, wir sprechen sehr viel über Sprachen lernen, aber es ist nun mal ein wichtiges Bestandteil in eurem Leben, vielleicht nicht, weil ihr einfach dumm seid, aber in unserem Leben schon, weil wir intellektuell sind. Und ich habe mir auch überlegt, eigentlich hätte ich Lust, so eine total altertümliche Ausdrucksweise, eine total altertümliche Ausdrucksweise zu haben. Also ich lerne ganz viele altertümliche Begriffe. Ich würde gerne, weil bei Duolingo kann ich nämlich, weil ich bezahle dafür, weil ich Duolingo Plus habe, ohne Werbung, mit anderen Sachen und so, habe ich jetzt genug Herzen gesammelt für Flirten. Ja. Und geiler wäre noch geiler als Flirten, wäre ja jetzt auch noch in der Verlängerung Altertumssprache oder so. Einfach Wörter, um wie ein verdammter Snob oder Sprachen-Crack zu wirken. Ich habe eine geniale Idee für unsere Vokabel-App. Duolingo meets Mortal Kombat. Du installierst die App und die App sagt dir, choose your character. Wer willst du sein?
Und dann hast du die Möglichkeit irgendwie 15-Jährige aus dem Pariser Umland oder Graf aus dem 18. Jahrhundert. Oder deutsche Austauschschüler, der gerade keinem was spricht. Und dann lernst du halt Französisch genau, wie die Person sprechen würde. Ja. Das ist ja genial. Und die App heisst das Podcast-Hufo. Du kannst dir so einen Charakter aussuchen, wenn du sein willst. Auch wenn du Englisch lernst, kannst du sagen, willst du so ein Texas-Cowboy sein? Willst du irgendwie so eine 16-Jährige aus London sein, die so einen ganz starken englischen Dialekt hat? Sowas, und dann kannst du da wirklich den Charakter aussuchen. Du hast doch viel mehr Bock zu lernen. Bei Duolingo hast du immer, weil du hast oben immer Sätze,
die musst du übersetzen, oft.
Und daneben ist so ein lustiger Charakter, so ein kleiner gezeichneter Charakter.
Und bei einem,
der hat so einen Tennisschläger und so ein Band und ist so ein Pumper, und bei dem
merkt man schon Muster, weil alle Sätze
von ihm sind immer, oh, kannst du mir kurz
zwei Millionen Dollar geben?
Ich hätte gerne 20 Millionen
Dollar. Ich spiele Tennis. Das sind so sehr viele Sachen, wo man immer sagt, okay, you're really a character, right? Ganz einfache Charakterzeichnung. Liebt Tennis und liebt Geld. Liebt Geld, einfach Geld. 30 Millionen, 40 Millionen. Tengo und Porsche. Oh, was heißt Leiden? Wieso nicht? Weiß man nicht. Aber finde ich eine geile Idee, dass man sich so Figuren nehmen kann. Weil mir haben dann auch Leute geschrieben so, ja, mach das und das, damit du auch so Umgangssprache lernst. Und ich dachte mir, was will ich denn Umgangssprache lernen? Ich will sprechen wie wirklich so ein Adliger aus dem 17. Jahrhundert. So will ich irgendwann mal in der französischen Bäckerei auftauchen und denen einfach mal wirklich da so einen Shakespeare-ähnlichen Satz vor die Füsse knallen, dass sie sich als Paundose-Shakespeare ist. Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Nee, bei irgendeiner Satre oder ein anderer krasser Typ. Ja, aber das darf man nicht fragen. Da sind die Franzosen sehr empfindlich, wenn du sagst, was ist der französische Shakespeare? Das ist der französische Shakespeare. Ja, weiss man nicht. Moliere vielleicht sowas in der Richtung oder einer von denen. Keine Ahnung. Wer? Weiss man nicht. Das ist ja ganz empfindlich. Man merkt schon beim Französischlernen, was da so empfindliche Fragen sind, die man nicht stellen darf. Dumas? Alexandre? Ja, vielleicht. Ich weiß ja, bei Französischen immer nicht. Ich habe immer Angst, wenn ich anfange, das Wort auszusprechen. Nur schön, immer nur schön. Dumont. Dumont? Dumonts? Weiss man nicht. Manchmal spricht man das Ende mit, mal nicht. Ganz schwierig ist zum Beispiel der französische Regisseur Alexandre ... Des ... Nee, der Komponist Despla. Despla. Nee, nee, nee, nee, warte mal, jetzt bin ich falsch. Fuck. Warte mal, Leute, pass auf, ihr könnt jetzt richtig schlau wirken. Genau, genau, Xavier Dolan. Und jetzt spricht man Dolan aus und nicht Dolan. Und alle sagen automatisch Dolan, Xavier Dolan. Aber leider, wenn man den korrekt ausspricht, spricht man ihn weniger französisch aus, als man ihn falsch.
Der ist nämlich einfach Servier Dolan.
Und das ist schwierig, weil du willst ja den anderen signalisieren.
Dolan, ja, eigentlich ist Dolan.
Du willst ja den Typ, der vorne sitzt und sagt, ja, dieser Dolan und du denkst die ganze Zeit so,
mhm, there was pure luck.
Man ist ja sauer.
Du verdienst diese Lorbeeren gerade nicht.
Und irgendein Typ, der denkt, er hätte Ahnung von einem Film, sagt Servier Dolan.
Und du denkst, nee, der heißt Dolan. Und der andere, nee, der heißt Dolan, der ist Franzose näher.
Sorry. Und du denkst dir, FRIEIN! Also ganz wichtig ist es genauso, es ist immer schwierig, wenn man mehr weiss als der, der so aussieht, als wüsste er viel. Das ist eine ganz schwierige Situation.
Es gibt nämlich zwei Arten. Entweder du weisst wirklich viel oder du weisst so viel, um gut zu wirken. Und das genau da an Dolan, Dolan, wie ich ihn nenne, wie ich ihn anders und falsch möglich. Dolan, also ich nenne ihn auch noch falscher, an dem scheiden sich die Geister. Genau, und man weiß nicht, soll ich es richtig sagen oder soll ich es so sagen, dass ich klug wirke. Alexander Dolan. Dolan, ja Dolly. Die Amis machen das sehr gut, die sagen einfach immer alles amerikanisch, sprechen die so aus. Ja, es ist eine schwere Welt, die Welt ist nicht gemacht für uns, intelligente Intelligenzien. Intelligenzien, ja, wir sind einfach, wir sind zu schlau. Wir hängen über allem drüber. Wir hängen über allem drüber. Was ist eigentlich aus deiner Stimme geworden? Weil da mein letzter Stand ist, Logopäden haben gesagt, also der Deutsche Rat der Logopäden hat es zusammengeschlossen, hat sehr laut miteinander und schön deutlich miteinander gesprochen, hat sich ausreden lassen, hat getagt. Und die haben gesagt, wir hören uns uns jetzt noch ein paar Folgen an, wir gucken uns das noch ein paar Folgen an. Ich stehe unter Beobachtung von führenden Logopäden dieses Landes. Ich bin mittlerweile Inhalt von verschiedenen Logopädie-Seminaren in ganz Deutschland. Und ja, ich bin ein Versuchsobjekt, ich bin ein lebendes Experiment. Fühlt du dich ein bisschen wie so eine Ratte in so einem Labyrinth? Absolut, ich fühle mich wie eine Ratte. Ich kriege auch so verschiedene Stimuli von denen, dass sie immer sagen, sag doch mal das, sag doch mal das, und ich bin lebendes Experiment, es fühlt sich nicht gut an, es ist so eine Frankenstein-Existenz, wo man nicht weiß, wie geht die Geschichte aus, aber ich glaube, es wird besser, also ohne jetzt auch zu primen in irgendeiner Richtung oder sowas, aber ich glaube, also ich habe das Gefühl, es wird wieder normal. Ach, ich weiß es nicht. Und ich habe auch keinen Bock.
Ich glaube, ich habe mir letztens überlegt, wie es wäre, wenn man halt einfach so ganz langsam, aber beständig einfach sein gesamtes Aussehen ändern würde. Wenn jemand im Laufe von drei Jahren einfach komplett anders aussieht, einfach ein anderes Gesicht, andere Gesichtszüge hat. Ich sehe schon anders aus. Aber man erkennt dich immer noch als Steve Dietz. Du bist schon immer noch The T-Master, du bist schon immer noch derselbe. Aber wenn du dich einfach in drei Jahren einfach aussehen würdest wie ein anderer Mensch, aber die Veränderung langsam genug ist, dass niemand jemals das anspricht, sondern man wirklich erst nach drei Jahren merkt so, du sieht vollkommen anders aus, vollkommen anders, aber es ist langsam genug.
Nee, genau, es ist erstmal so die Schuhe, erstmal andere Schuhe, dann irgendwann andere Hosen, dann irgendwann so, weil, kennt man ja auch aus Videospielen, man hat nicht sofort Geld für eine ganz neue Rüstung, und dann hat man plötzlich, Erst mal so die Armbänder, so die ganzen wenigen.
Was mich immer so genervt hat bei Guild Wars, hat mich immer so genervt, weil ich wollte immer so ein cooler Elementar, so ein hotter Elementarmagier sein, so mit so einem geilen, komplett weissen Outfit oder komplett rot, keine Ahnung, irgendwas. Und dann hast du irgendwo so eine Rüstung gefunden, so ein Einarmstück, oft waren es dann beide Arme, und es war dann besser als deine Rüstung, aber hat halt farblich so gar
nicht gepasst. Hat alles ruiniert.
Ich war immer so sauer. Weil dann musste man es ja
nehmen, weil man besser gerüstet ist.
Aber es sieht echt hässlich aus. Ja, es ist immer schwierig.
Und man muss sich langsam
angleichen. Das meine ich ja. Man muss langsam die weisse Rüstung
zusammenstellen. Man muss sich langsam angleichen.
Und irgendwann trägst du einfach Tweet-Sacko,
also so einen Tweet-Anzug
und alle denken, vor drei Jahren
hast du noch Podcasts und so scherzgetragen.
What's up, man? Im Tierreich
Vielen Dank. Und irgendwann trägst du einfach Tweet-Sacko, also so ein Tweet-Anzug und alle denken, vor drei Jahren hast du noch Podcasts-Fusherz getragen, what's up, man? Im Tierreich ist es völlig normal, dass du als Raupe startest und irgendwann sagst du, wow, habt ihr mal gesehen, wie ich vor drei Jahren aussah? Ich war da irgendwie so ein kleines Ruf umliegen. Mir ist es nicht selber nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe auch Fotos gesehen, die sind von mir vor drei Jahren. Genau, wie sah ich denn damals aus? Ich hatte keine Flügel, komplett gerün, rödel da durch die Gegend. Warum habt ihr denn nichts gesagt? Ich sah aus wie ein Vollidiot. Ja, guck mal, weil ich habe doppelt, nein, dreifach, nein, vierfach Kinn. Mein ganzer Körper ist eigentlich eine Aneinanderreihung von Kinn, Doppelkinn. Warum habt ihr denn nichts gesagt? Naja, wir dachten, du findest schon noch deinen Stil. Du findest dich wohl so. Wer sind denn wirklich zu judgen? Nee, aber ich sah ja offensichtlich aus wie ein kompletter Trottel. Ja, Bodyshaming wäre das jetzt. Nee, aber da kann man schon mal was sagen. Oder so eine Raupe, eine von den Raupen, die ihr Leben lang raupen bleiben, kriegt das Gespräch mit und kriecht wütend weg. Genau, der Regenwurm, der denkt, eines Tages sehe ich auch noch schön aus. Welcher wunderschöner Schmetterling. Welcher wunderschöner Schmetterling.
Aber da im Tierreich ist es völlig normal, dass man komplett sein Aussehen verändert, der Mensch im Grunde immer gleich.
Wie erinnert die Melodie von das Großkrabbel?
Toller Film.
Aber auch nicht so gut gealtert.
Die Animation ist nicht so wahnsinnig gut gealtert.
Naja, aber das ist schon okay. Bei Disney-Plaster Plus habe ich nämlich alle solche Sachen geguckt. Ganz, ganz toll. Diese Disney-Pixar-Filme. Ich habe Up noch nie gesehen, den wollte ich mir dringend mal anschauen. Schau ihn rückwärts an, dann hat er ein gutes Ende. Up fand ich war ein frustrierender Film. Wieso? Rückwärts ist so einfach nur, Mann landet mit, rückwärts ist Up, Down erstens, wird es heißen.
Und dann am Ende lebt die Frau.
Happy End. Ne, es ist im Prinzip,
er landet mit seinem
Ballonhaus irgendwo in der Stadt
und wiederbelebt seine
Frau. Genau. Das wäre doch
Down. Das wäre doch
Up, rückwärts.
Genau, der zweite Teil von Up, Down. It's going down. Welche eine ganz gute Idee. Aber es ist schon schwierig, manche Filme bewerte man einfach nach dem Ende. Deswegen habe ich Up einfach nicht als guten Film in Erinnerung, weil du diesen weirden Hund mit dem weirden Abenteuer. Hallo, ich habe gerade gesagt, dass ich noch nicht guckt habe. Ja, aber wenn die in der Eiswelt sind, dann müssen die ganzen Pinguine auftauchen, in dieser komischen Forschungsstation und so.
Ich will die ganzen emotionalen Kram vom Anfang wieder haben.
Nee, da sprichst du mich, ich spiele jetzt auf.
Nee, Ab ist ein guter Film zum Einschlafen, weil der ist am Anfang gut und dann irgendwann döst du weg und du hast die gute in Erinnerung.
Ich schlafe dabei überall immer ein, immer noch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie er das da draußen macht, ob er das überhaupt noch irgendwer gerade hört, aber ich höre Podcasts immer noch die ersten zehn Minuten. Und halt dann das Abheben. Dann bist du wieder wach und dann bist du hellwach, drei Uhr nachts und dann mittelgst du hier. Dann schreckt man auch und denkt, was habe ich da gerade gehört? Was ist eine Worst Bird? Und wir haben euch alles ins Unterbewusstsein eingeredet. Kauft Merch. Ich würde gerne mal was an eigener Sache kurz mal ansprechen. Könnt ihr bitte mal, weil es auch ein kleines Experiment, könnt ihr bitte mal auf IMDB gehen, Internet Movie Database, kennt ihr ja? Ja. Mittlerweile hat es sich ja funktisch. Und zehn Sterne geben folgender Serie. Und wirklich mal einfach, bitte,
oh Scheiss,
der Serie How to Sell Drugs Online Fast
zehn Sterne geben.
Ernsthaft? Ja, weil
das ist aber jetzt wirklich betrugt einfach,
ist ja schon klar. Nee, wieso? Ich finde die
ganz okay, die Serie. Das ist Wettbewerbsverzerrung.
Ich finde die ganz okay gelungen. Ich fand sie auch okay, es ist keine
zehn Sterne-Serie, aber es ist okay. Aber
da jetzt zu sagen. Aber guck mal, weil wir haben,
weil ich finde es auch echt lustig,
weil so haben,
weil ich finde es auch echt lustig, weil
so ab, also ich finde es schon cool,
wenn es einfach über acht wäre.
Gerade 7,9.
Ja, du willst einfach mehr als der Pate.
Nee, der Pate
ist doch bestimmt bei 8,9 oder sowas.
Ja, ja. Nee, so viel muss ich gar nicht haben,
aber so eine 8,0
wäre schon gut. Du willst die 8. Ja, stimmt, 7,9 ist so. Undankbar. Ist richtig undankbar. Ich glaube, da waren so ein paar Hater dabei, die uns, also deswegen, weil ein Kumpel von uns hat ausgerechnet, weil wir haben jetzt 17.000 Stimmen bekommen, das sind auch gar nicht so viele Stimmen. Also wenn da jetzt einfach, ich glaube, es reichen so 150 Leute rum, hat der immer ausgerechnet, mit 10 Sterne Bewertungen undewertungen und wir können die achten kratzen, Leute. Ich finde das mal einfach ganz spannend. Es ist super billig gerade der Aufruf. Es ist extrem billig gerade, aber ich bin begeistert. Aber ich finde es wirklich spannend, weil wir haben jetzt Stand der Aufnahme 17.790 Stimmen, die abgestimmt haben, im Schnitt für,9. Ich fände es cool, lass uns alle zehn Sterne geben. Vielleicht geht es nach hinten los und es werden ganz viele einen Stern geben. Vielleicht. Und wir ziehen es dann am Ende runter. Und du bist zu hoch geflogen und es ist eine gute Lektion, dass man sich auch wirklich gute Bewertungen erarbeiten muss und nicht einfach da irgendwie Leute draufhetzen kann. Aber es wäre doch auch noch lustiger, wenn es funktionieren würde einfach. Und am Ende, weil ich finde es cool.
Was können wir erreichen?
Wo kriegen wir diese Zahl hingejazzt?
Endlich mal was Gutes getan.
Ich gebe dir zehn Sterne, ich gehe wieder von meiner sieben Sterne Bewertung zurück,
korrigiere mich nochmal nach oben.
Weil du diesen Polizisten doof fandest.
Der war echt langweilig, der hatte so wenig Text.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sollte eigentlich.
Du warst nur sauer, weil wir dich umbringen wollten. Ich wollte mich umbringen? Mich persönlich nach dem Dreh. Ach, ihr wart jetzt in dem Auto, die hinter mir hergefahren sind. Ne, die Rolle. Achso, was? Was? Was hast du gerade gesagt? No. Ah, Schumappel. Schumappel. Ja, das wollte ich nochmal sagen, also fände ich irgendwie cool. Ja, okay, dann kann ich auch was aus eigener Sache machen. Ja, mach ich mal. Ich gebe euch mal eine Kontonummer durch und dann wäre es cool, wenn jeder von euch mal so ein, zwei Euro mir einfach überweisen könnte. Einfach mal, um zu gucken, wie viele Leute schicken. Einfach mal muss nicht viel, genau, DE47 000000182. Und da einfach mal, einfach mal 10 Cent reichen, einfach mal aus Gag, einfach mal 10 Cent einfach mal schicken und gucken, was passiert. 182, wann will ich die erste Nummer meiner Konto-Nmer? Ich weiß. Woher weißt du das? Ich weiß, Anna Stefan. Bist du Rita95? Ich bin Rita? Hat was mit Anna zu tun, Ausrufezeichen. Ich bin Rita. Hat was mit Anna zu tun. Irgendwo Schwager, Schwägerin, Tante. Kommt irgendwo so aus der Anna-Richtung, grob. Glaube französische Austauschschülerin, aber bin nicht sicher. Grobe Anna-Richtung, Anna oder Antje, eine von beiden, einfach irgendwie sowas. Irgendwas mit A. Einfach Vergangenheit, Stefan hat keine gute Arbeit geleistet. Und dann zwöl ich so hoch, wenn man nochmal Antje, wenn man nochmal Antje steht dann so, hat grob was mit Tobi zu tun. Wie lief es eigentlich mit deinem Spiel, mit deinem Detektivspiel? Noch nicht gespielt. Noch nicht gespielt? Nein. Du hast es empfohlen, ein Spiel für möglicherweise eine Person.
Ah, das erinnert mich aber, dass du uns deine Amazon-Warenkorb zeigen kannst.
Ja, das habe ich nicht parat. Das geht auf Wiedervorlage, das werde ich nachreichen.
Wir vergessen nicht.
Also da bin ich nicht informiert. Da werde ich das nachreichen. Was hast du zu verbergen? Reichen, das ist, da habe ich, das ist ausserhalb meines Zuständigkeitsbereichs. Ja. Da werde ich zeitnah Dokumente nachreichen in intensiver Recherche, werde ich das auf jeden Fall nachführen. Dieschuldigung, steht nicht im Verhältnis.
Nein, also das wird, das nehme ich auf meine eigene Kappe, mea culpa, das wird nachgereicht. Okay, das finde ich gut. Glaubst du, Kim Jong-un hat so eine Pressekonferenz gemacht und war danach so genervt, dass er gesagt hat, müssen wir das machen? Nee, wir sind Diktator, dann lassen wir das doch einfach. Aber das war so unangenehm, einfach so diese eine Pressekonferenz und dann einfach so, wo kommt ihr ganzes Geld her? Wie so ein Kind, was lernt, dass man auch lügen kann. Oder hat Hitler nicht auch eine Pressekonferenz gemacht damals nach Amtsantritt, so pro forma eine Pressekonferenz und dann so stimmt es, dass ihr Gehalt nicht versteuert wird. Das lassen sich ja alles
sein. Also da bin ich jetzt nicht im Bilde,
das werde ich nicht nachreichen.
Und einfach.
Und jetzt bereut ihr, dass ihr
keinen Imitationspodcast
nachgebracht habt. Podcast Parody.
Dass ihr uns Imitations
Pingpong. Paradise. Paradise.
Paradise. Paradise.
Paradise. Paradise. Paradise, Paradise, Paradise, the parody podcast.
Nein, nicht, Paradise, von parody und podcast. Oder Paradise,ist. Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys. Children, ihr könnt das nicht drucken, ihr könnt das wirklich nicht drucken. Kids. Kids, the Pedarist Podcast. Es funktioniert nicht, Leute, stopp. Wir müssen sämtliche Werbeeinnahmen zurückgeben. Aber eigentlich ist Paddle-Rice doch gar nicht so schlecht. Also so wie Paradise. Das ist ganz schlecht. Halt so wie Paradies. Paddle-Rice. The Parody Podcast. Paradise. Aber eigentlich so eine lustige Vorstellung. So zwei Guys wie wir, die halt irgendwie die ganze Zeit gute Epideen haben, aber halt es schadet an den Namen. Katastrophale Namen, Idee zehn von zehn, Namen, null von zehn. Aber ich finde also so wie Paradies, Paradise, wie Parody Paradise, finde ich gar nicht schlecht eigentlich. Macht mal einen Parodie-Podcast und dann parodiert man Mordlust, irgendwie Herrengedeck, Feuer und Brot, könnt ihr alle parodieren? Ja, diese Zeitverbrechen, mega, Einschlafen-Podcast, mega, Herrengedeck, die ganzen beste Freundinnen, mega zu parodieren. Finde ich richtig gut. Auch gemischtes Hack-Wir, mega zu parodieren. Feste Flauschig, natürlich unglaublich gut zu parodieren, auch Gäste letzte Geisterbahn, toll zu parodieren. Super, super einfach zu parodieren. Gefühlte Fakten, toll zu parodieren. Hau das mal raus, hau das mal raus und dann können wir ja nächste Woche die Top 3 der Padrest-Best-Padrest-Podcasts prämieren. Und der Gewinner kriegt einen schönen Wagen. Oder wollen wir das bei uns, wollen wir das mal, ihr könnt uns ja, weil wir haben auch schon sehr viele Intros mittlerweile, schickt uns doch mal so eine einminütige Parodie eines Podcasts. Finde ich gut, als Segment. Und dann streamen wir das demnächst als Element ab. Wir halten uns rechtlich vor, das abzuschmettern. Ja, und wir werden nur die, wir schicken nicht zu allen eine Kritik, das schaffen wir wahrscheinlich nicht, aber wir würden die besten, würden wir ausstrahlen über die nächsten Wochen. Ja. Maximal, maximal drei Minuten. Ja, nee, nee, zwei Minuten. Maximal zwei Minuten. Ja, nee, eine Minute, eins, reise. Maximal zwei Minuten. Nee, zwei. Nein, du musst auch Rubriken parodieren können. Ja, stimmt. Du brauchst doch schon ein bisschen Raum. Ja, ja. Maximal zwei Minuten. So lange, wie es trägt. Nee. Also zweieinhalb, zweie wir aus Antenne Afrika eins gelernt haben, dann ist es ein Zeitlimit einführen. Dann das ein ganzer Kontinent nicht trägt. Es reicht nicht. We are Africa. Wir sind, dieser Podcast ist Afrika. You are Africa. Maybe. Wir sind so. Also deswegen fände ich das gut. Zwei Minuten. Ihr da draußen gefällt, das ist eure Chance. Und wenn ihr richtig gut parodiert, dann vielleicht kommt ihr zu Thais noch und uns beiden in den Cast. Ja. Wenn ihr gut parodieren könnt. Weil ich finde es mega. Einen guten Päderasten bei uns zu haben. Parodisten. Padoristen. Falls ihr ein Pädorist seid, dann schickt uns bitte so eine Art Tape ein und zeigt mal, was ihr könnt. Wir finden das richtig gut. Ansonsten haut rein. Wünschen wir euch eine ganz, ganz schöne Woche. Richtig schöne Woche. Und erinnere mich nächste Woche mal an meine fantastische App-Idee. Ich habe wirklich die beste App-Idee, die wir jemals hier gesagt haben, und ich bin heute nicht dazugekommen. Nächste Wochele, beste App-Idee und ansonsten alles weitere.
Und dann Amazon-Barenkorb.
Macht diese Woche zur schönsten Woche eures bisherigen Jahres.
Macht das Wetter draus.
Macht's gut.
Macht's gut, bis dann, wir heben ab.
Ciao, macht's gut, ciao.
To do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do